hey I'm going up to fuckman's LEAP to
have some cordials later wanna come what
wow
completely I don't know what you're
talking about everybody got lost with
that well it'll come out
no please leave it yeah
I don't know it just came out wait so
you don't even that's not even a real
thing I don't know what it is who
improvises fuckman's leap that's insane
that is not coming out that is a pure
moment of insanity out of my mouth
before but I don't know what it is
man hey dudes we were on a riff about
you being Square in front of Billy
eilish and then your attempts to be a
quote Square guy is to say we're all
going up to fuckman's League which for
the record is the coolest sounding place
I've ever heard in my life and boom that
shows that I've got it
I wanna die on fuckman's League